moi j'adore rire
c'est vrai j'adore rire et j'adore être
mais je pense qu'on voilà en plus c'est
ce qui est pas mal avec notre métier
c'est qu'on peut on peut se permettre
d'être un peu
enfantin toute notre vie quoi
coucou je m'appelle Adèle exarcopoulos
coucou je m'appelle Vincent Lacoste et
on est ici à Cannes pour présenter le
prochain Disney Pixar qui s'appelle
l'élémentaire
en plus la tuyauterie m'a déformé
donc tu n'es jamais sorti de Fire Town
désolé on est pas compatible
mon père te ferait bouillir à feu vif
mais de quel droit les gens peuvent te
dire ce que tu es censé faire ou pas
[Musique]
c'était mon rêve de faire un Picard
pourquoi parce que moi je consomme
beaucoup de dessins animés de manga
depuis que je suis petit et puis
aujourd'hui j'ai une autre lecture vu
que j'ai grandi et donc il y a 7 double
lecture dans les dessins animés ou
forcément la morale te parle dans
différemment la lucidité t'amène
d'autres messages et en même temps cette
émerveillement moi ça m'a sur beaucoup
les dessins animés donc c'est un rêve
pour moi de d'en faire partie moi j'ai
un peu j'ai grandi oui aussi avec les
pixars donc c'était vraiment je suis un
immense fan de mille et une pattes des
mots ratatouille enfin donc c'est vrai
que c'était un
[Rires]
regard
non et donc c'est vrai que voilà j'étais
j'étais à fond il y a une vraie pâte
Pixar qui fait qu'il y a à chaque fois
d'une grande humanité une grande
sensibilité dans les films et beaucoup
de de voilà de de
voilà
moi je sais que j'ai besoin dans ma vie
du rire de l'autodérision du second
degré sinon c'est pas possible donc je
pense que moi ma part d'enfance ça passe
vachement à travers le rire ouais moi
aussi franchement c'est moi j'adore rire
c'est vrai j'adore rire et j'adore être
mais je pense qu'on voilà en plus c'est
ce qui est pas mal avec notre métier
c'est qu'on peut on peut se permettre
d'être un peu enfant toute notre vie
passage oui se lever le matin et se dire
bonjour au travail c'est de mettre un
costume qui est pas le mien de de de
d'avoir une morale qui n'est pas la même
mais la jouer en fait ça je trouve ça
déjà super enfantin c'est comme quand tu
disais ta mère regarde j'ai fait un truc
de fou
nul et tout le monde te regarde donc il
y a ce truc là de de risques et de jeux
et moi je pense que c'est ça
moi je trouve que le lien que j'ai avec
mon personnage c'est son sens de la
famille après j'avoue que je me je me
ressens pas du tout aussi colérique
qu'elle serait incapable de piquer de
quoi je te remercie mon pote non mais de
toute façon c'est vrai que je suis pas
du tout colérique moi je pense que je
suis assez gentil comme Flak et sinon je
suis pas enfin je suis assez émotif mais
bon genre quand je regarde un film ou
machin mais le sujet assez pudique
contrairement à FLAC et sinon je suis
je suis attachant
c'était je pense que c'était la
projection de la vie d'Adèle comme il y
a 10 ans
moi c'est je pense c'est la projection
du film de Christophe Honoré que ça va
te plaire aimer quoi invite donc c'était
j'adore ce film c'était vraiment
vraiment très émouvant quoi
merci à vous